[Music]
the fact that these remains are coming
up
if it is him
[Music]
i want to do the right thing and take
care of him
a daughter who lost her father 18 years
ago believes remains discovered at lake
mead could be him and tonight the
coroner has yet to identify the body
that was found floating at the end of
last month that discovery while gruesome
giving this family some renewed hope we
do want to caution you the images may be
upsetting the eight news now i-team's
david charns speaking with them
exclusively as we learn more about who
this person may be yeah brian and denise
this family hoping that person
is kenneth funk an army veteran who
drowned rescuing his wife in a boating
accident decades ago
that's where he loved to be
when you look at photos of kenneth funk
lake mead often fills in the scenery him
chilling out at the lake it's the
saturday before father's day in june
2004 funk then 56 was on a pontoon boat
with his wife annette when a wave hit
throwing her into the depths of boulder
basin funk jumped in he gave her the
life jacket and
they tried they were in the water
together as close as me and you are
right now
and treaded water as long as he could
eventually he could tread water no
longer he put his head back he closed
his eyes and he went under my dad knew
he he knew it was there was no way out
for him
and he knew that he if he she held onto
him she would pull she would go down
with him we'll be conducting search
operations twice a day for the next
three weeks video from that time shows
rangers searching that water then 300
feet deep kenneth funk was never found
he saved her sacrificed himself
basically condon says she was told her
father's remains would likely never be
recovered but there was always hope for
18 years it's every year when there's
ever there's a drowning out there if
there's ever been you know hey we found
a body out here i've kind of prepared
myself for it
that day came in late july when swimmers
found a torso floating near the shore
it's built like my dad the stomach the
chest the back condon provided dna to
the coroner's office in arizona when
rangers found bones several years ago
she says she never heard back the fact
that these remains are coming up
if it is him
i want to do the right thing and take
care of him that includes a proper
burial the family installing a cross on
an island nearby
hoping others think about just who it
represents that represents someone
that's lost their life
out here for some reason so maybe we
need to
stop slow down
put our life jacket on so that we don't
have these accidents and we don't have
these tragedies
as you saw there the the conditions of
the remains are pretty well preserved
and that's possibly from being in cool
water for so many years we asked a local
doctor about what he sees in those
photos and he believes this person
likely died in a more violent way
you're not just going to like lose an
arm it's not going to get soft in the
shoulder area on the right side or right
and left side and the arms kind of
spontaneously break off
and they're not going to do it in a
clean fashion right now the case is not
considered considered suspicious but
that could change pending what the
coroner determines because the family
already submitted dna they could get
answers soon as in several months i'm
david charns live local now